So here's my code for the dateIsBefore helper procedure. If year1 is before
year2 then we can return True right away. We don't care about the months and
the days if the years are different. If the years are equal then we need to look
at the months. If month1 is before month2, we return True. If the month's were
the same, then we look at the days. And note that we don't have elses here. But
if we don't hit the returns we're going to fall through to this last statement
and return False. And that could happen if either year1 is greater than year2,
or the years are equal and month1 is greater than month2, or the months are
equal and day1 is greater than day2. In all of those cases, the first date is
not in before the second date and we should return False.